hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2010 american action
and fantasy movie called the sorcerer's
apprentice
the movie begins in britain in 740 a.d
when the powerful sorcerer merlin
teaches his secrets and powers to three
apprentices balthazar veronica and
horvath in order to win the war between
sorcerers
one day the evil sorceress morgana leffe
invades his castle and kills merlin due
to the betrayal of horvath who decides
to pick sides with the evil morgana
acquires the power to raise an army of
the dead despite arriving late veronica
sacrifices herself for balthazar and
humankind by absorbing the soul of
morgana into her own body
since morgana begins to kill veronica
from the inside balthazar captures both
of them in an inescapable prison called
grimhold he eventually traps horvath in
the vase-shaped prison as well merlin
with his dying breath gives his last
remaining apprentice his dragon ring
ordering him to give it to a prime
merlinian a chosen merlin successor who
is the only one that can entirely defeat
morgana
the scene jumps to the year 2000 in new
york city where a 10 year old dave
stuttler goes on a field trip with the
school he falls in love with one of the
students becky and attempts to ask her
whether she wants to be his girlfriend
or not by sending her a small note she
then leaves it on the bench after
answering it unfortunately when dave
tries to pick it up the note flies away
due to strong wind he chases after it
and eventually comes across an antique
shop called arcana cabana he is amazed
with the stored stuff there and almost
breaks one of the antiques while
balthazar shows up and catches it dave
mentions that he was looking for a note
and then just coincidentally ended up
here after hearing that he hands him
merlin's dragon's ring which suddenly
comes alive and twirls around dave's
finger
he concludes that dave is the prime
merlinian
while balthazar is looking for something
in the basement dave tries the ring
which manages to bump the wall every
time he moves his finger a grim hold of
horvath lands in front of him not
knowing that it stores a dangerous
sorcerer within it he accidentally opens
it and horvath breaks free balthazar
appears and pushes him toward the
ceiling with his magic the foe fights
back and an epic wizard battle ensues in
the building they exchange attacks and
it seems like they have an even skill
and power
while horvath tries to take a grimhold
that dave is holding an ancient urn
opens and sucks both him and balthazar
into it dave immediately escapes the
building and throws the grimhold into
the street he reunites with his teacher
and friends talking nonsense about
sorcerers and magic battle inside the
building the teacher goes into the shop
and finds nothing his friends laugh at
him when they see he wets his pants
despite him trying to explain that it is
caused by a jar filled with water that
had broken
ten years later dave has grown up and
lives with a friend bennett turns out
that he still keeps the dragon ring with
him he is now a physics student at new
york university there he finally meets
becky again since they were 10.
he talks to her and the woman still
remembers him for his silly action at
the arcana cabana
after class dave follows becky who
reveals that now she works at the
college radio station
suddenly lightning strikes the station
antenna since he is a physics nerd dave
offers to help and gets it all fixed
becky is very impressed and he goes away
after that
at his own private lab in a basement he
hears the song played by becky on the
radio and attempts to replay the rhythms
of the song but with lightning bolts
that create sounds meanwhile the
grimhold that traps balthazar and
horvath bursts open and horvath breaks
free
he immediately throws it off the window
luckily balthazar manages to escape from
it before it smashes to the ground
dave returns home and finds horvath who
asks him where is the grimhold that he
held 10 years ago he admits that he
threw it into the street and immediately
runs away horvath summons a pack of
wolves and they chase after dave as soon
as the wolves attack him they suddenly
turn into cute puppies
not long after balthazar appears with a
giant metal eagle and rescues dave
before getting hit by the train horvath
also manages to survive
at the roof of a building balthazar
explains that horvath wants to free his
fellow morganians and enslave humans
dave begs the sorcerer to keep him out
of the sorcerer's problems and lives a
normal life
balthazar discovers that the ring is
still with him and orders him to help
him get the grim hold back he promises
that dave can walk away after finding
the vase
using balthazar's ability to track a
grimhold they manage to locate it which
is stored at chinatown dave waits
outside while balthazar goes inside the
house
upstairs he meets horvath who disguises
himself as an old chinese woman and
attacks him with a magic spell however
he manages to release one of the
morganians sunlock who gets knocked out
of the building by balthazar using his
belt sunlock transforms a fake dragon
costume into a real dragon which chases
dave
meanwhile balthazar ties horvath up and
retrieves the grimhold initially having
problems casting the magic dave
eventually manages to throw a fireball
on time and they defeat sunlock
balthazar is a man of his word he asks
dave to return the ring to him since he
has helped him but dave changes his mind
and requests the sorcerer to train him
he hides the grim hold in dave's private
lab where he turns dave into a sorcerer
dave steps inside merlin's circle and he
officially becomes balthazar's
apprentice the training begins where he
explains that all sorcerers need the
ring to cast a magic spell or they will
be powerless and teaches him how to cast
a plasma bolt dave also learns how to
control and create lightning bolts on
the other side orvath starts to gather
the army he visits the current living
morganian drake stone and asks for his
help while having dinner outside becky's
radio station dave spots becky and
decides to approach her leaving the old
man alone the two go down into the
subway station where a mugger robs becky
he chases after him and clumsily uses
his magic to knock him out he returns to
becky with her stuff back which
impresses her since dave is weak and the
robber is much bigger than him he
invites the girl to his lab to study
physics together which she agrees to the
next day becky arrives at the lab and he
introduces balthazar as his uncle there
dave manages to perform a cool musical
show with his tesla coils which
surprises the girl since it is the music
that she played on the radio previously
the next day drake confronts dave in the
university bathroom and starts attacking
him not long after horvath arrives and
threatens to kill him he demands to know
where the grimhold is but fortunately
balthazar shows up just in time he
knocks out drake and traps horvath
inside the bathroom mirror back at the
lab balthazar explains that the grimhold
actually holds morgana who wants to rule
the earth by resurrecting the dead he
also reveals that he is a prime
merlinian who is able to cast magic
without a ring
realizing that becky will arrive soon he
attempts to clean up the lab but gets
frustrated with the mess with the
cleaning spell he decides to bring the
brooms and the mops alive while he goes
to shower
however as he returns the auto cleaning
brooms transform the lab into a bigger
mess with the entire floor flooded
becky arrives at the lab but he has to
tell her to leave dave is overwhelmed
and almost gets electrocuted by his own
lab equipment but balthazar shows up and
cleans all the mess with a single hand
wave balthazar scolds and reminds him
not to abuse the sacred art of magic
dave is fed up with all the expectations
that balthazar demands and eventually
gives up saying that he chose the wrong
person to become a prime merlinian
he then walks out of the lab
meanwhile horvath obtains the school
records of dave and finds out the
location of his private lab space
dave sees becky hanging out with her
friends and leaves
becky spots him and secretly follows him
to the roof of the chrysler building
where she tries to fix the botched date
earlier because of the brooms she tells
him that she is impressed with all the
effort he has done at the lab balthazar
is attacked by drake who disguises
himself as dave while he is trapped
orvath arrives and manages to discover
morgana's grimhold which is invisible he
also reveals that he betrayed merlin
because of heartbreak
they were once best friends but veronica
chose balthazar to be her lover instead
of him he frees himself but horvath
launches a set of knives towards him
luckily dave arrives and manages to
prevent the knives from moving further
the traitor and drake run away while
dave and balthazar chase after them the
car pursuit with magically changing
vehicles ensues
horvath gets his revenge by trapping
them inside a mirror they manage to
escape from there but the foes
eventually get away as dave transforms
their car into an old 73 pinto and gets
crushed by their truck
after acquiring morgana's grimhold
horvath steals drake's power and life in
order to release the next morganian
abigail williams since he doesn't need
him anymore she then goes to becky's
radio station and kidnaps her
unfortunately horvath eliminates the
poor sorceress as soon as he gets what
he wants and takes her necklace
dave and balthazar arrive at drake's
apartment and split up the sorcerer gets
trapped in a persian quick rug trap
while dave retrieves the grimhold
as soon as he reaches the door he meets
horvath who holds becky hostage he
forces dave to hand over the grimhold
and his dragon ring in exchange for
becky's safety which he agrees to
balthazar finally frees himself and
catches up with the others but he is too
late however he understands dave's
decision since he would have done the
same thing
after that balthazar decides to go after
horvath alone since dave is still unable
to cast any spells without his ring
dave explains everything to his lover
and she wants to get involved in the
sorcerer's business
dave calls his roommate who helps him to
install tesla coils to balthazar's car
he also finds a note with a necklace
telling him to give it to veronica when
this is all over the trio immediately
head to battery park where horvath plans
to release morgana still in veronica's
body morgana reawakens and starts the
ceremony to raise the dead by creating a
huge circle
dave pulls over and tells becky to move
the antenna on the top of the building
to disrupt the awakening ceremony back
at the park balthazar sneaks in but gets
spotted by horvath he fights his former
best friend while morgana slowly revives
the morganian all around the world he
summons a huge steel bull to attack
balthazar but luckily dave arrives and
attacks horvath with the car while the
steel eagle snatches the bull away
just before morgana's circle is
completed becky moves the antenna which
cancels the ceremony and knocks morgana
unconscious
balthazar absorbs morgana's soul from
veronica's body freeing her after that
he orders dave to trap him in the grim
hole but veronica refuses
morgana leaves the body and finally
stands with her own body she casts a
fire blast towards the group but dave
eventually manages to block it without
the help of a ring balthazar receives
the damage of morgana's plasma bolts
when he tries to protect veronica thanks
to dave's knowledge and physics he
manages to attack the evil sorceress
with high voltage thunderbolts and
defeats her after a ruthlessly strikes
her with the plasma bolts
balthazar is dead after trying to save
veronica but dave manages to resurrect
him with his magic spell the couple then
kiss and becky finally reveals that she
accepted him as his boyfriend written in
the note he gave 10 years earlier as
they kiss for the first time
at the end of the movie it is scene
horvath takes his hat from balthazar's
shop indicating that he is still alive
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching